non mais je veux aller au bout de la
question devient le match parce qu'au
fond qu'on ne répondait pas moi j'ai
gardé le souvenir de certaines de vos
déclarations où vous ne mettez pas sur
le même plan d'égalité
l'amour entre homosexuels ou entre
hétérosexuels d'affiliation pas dû à un
mauvais nom mais je veux que vous
répondiez à ses associés c'est la
question de presse que est ce que pour
vous c'est la même chose un amour entre
deux homosexuels ou dans un coupé mais
on sait que je suis pas l'amour mais
bien sûr ils ont fait des déclarations
inverse a dû tous les décès elle je n'ai
pas fait des classes en ce sens nous dit
c'est pas exactement le même lit il n'y
a pas une pas du tout j'ai jamais dit ça
mais est ce que vous avez trouvé que
j'ai digéré me dit ça faisait très bien
documenté vous offre mon livre le temps
de loeb vous voyez ce qui a marqué
dedans je n'en avais loin dans votre
livre j'ai pas dit que j'étais jeune
j'ai souvenir de déclarer je ne parle
pas au contraire je reconnais l'accord
je reconnais y compris l'amour que des
personnes peuvent porter un enfant mais
je dis que ce n'est pas tout
ce n'est pas tout l'amour est une chose
mais il ya aussi les repères et c'est
mal et j'ai voulu écrire sur un saut de
l'amour et de la bienveillance de la
bientraitance et je ne dis pas non plus
que des enfants qui sont élevés donc
c'est biologique en fait vous voulez que
pour des raisons biologiques mais vous
n'êtes ni d'un homme et d'une femme
oui mais elle aurait alors eu vent des
repères alors puisqu'il
quand thierry qui est un géniteur c'est
donc la même chose géniteurs et par an
vous voyez pas dans le mot de parents
une noblesse supplémentaires qui
viendraient qu'on se détériore fondé la
biologie et finalement la culture et la
nature ou les associés et c'est comme ça
que naît la barbarie mon cher monsieur
lennon mais je sais bien que j'ai c'est
bien qu'être un géniteur engagé une
certaine responsabilité et si vous avez
subi comme beaucoup trop d'enfants et
jenny la balle à monsieur et quand vous
dites que le corps qu'à vous de l'état
de la matière bien sûr si une
marchandise le corps quand on vous
greffe un coeur bien sûr c'est de la
marchandise est pas le cas il faut pas
avoir de regrets
route irish ne s'est pas encore exprimée
est ce que c'est important qu'il y ait
débat pour justement parler de ces
derniers mais c'est pas parce qu'il ya
des risques qu'il faut tout dans ce cas
là on n'aurait jamais avancé sur rien
parce qu'à chaque fois il ya un an il y
à chaque fois un problème est ce que tu
as dit tout à l'heure est vrai il faut
donc le régler et c'est pour ça qu'ils
aient une loi c'est pour ça qu'ils aient
une discussion
moi j'ai toujours du mal on parle il ya
dit à l'heure vous parlez pour les
enfants j'ai aussi du mal lorsqu'on
donne des leçons de féminisme aux femmes
ont fait quand on est un homme moi ça me
gêne toujours de dire ces femmes
devraient dire ça je suis assez mal
placé pour dire ce qu'elle devrait dire
moi je sais tu kamala harris qui quand
elle recevait le juge calque amano qui
allait être qui était auditionné pour
être donc à la cour suprême
elle lui avait dit mais pouvez vous lui
donnez nous pouvons donner une loi d'un
gouvernement a le pouvoir de prendre des
décisions concernant le corps mal et en
fait il y avait rien et je trouve qu'à
chaque fois on oublie ça on oublie ça
parce qu'il se trouve qu'actuellement
des femmes vont ailleurs le faire donc
certaines fables pendant qu'est ce qu'on
en fait on peut quand même prendre ce
qui va sans doute les personnes les plus
riches donc dans la notion d'égalité
il faut prendre toutes les notions en
ligne de compte et les mettre au fond du
débat mais c'est pas parce qu'il ya des
dérives qu'on doit tout dire c'est fini
ça s'arrête
non